- [Instructor] So in this video,
we're going to think
about dividing numbers
where the quotient, the
result of our division,
might result in a decimal.
So let's say we wanted to compute
what five divided by two is.
In the past, you might've said,
hey, two times two is four
and then you'd have one leftover
and so you might have
said something like this,
this is two with a remainder of one.
But now we don't want,
we don't wanna just say,
hey, how many times can it
go in and what's left over.
We wanna know exactly how many
times can two go into five
so we want a decimal
answer right over here.
So, pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
And there's many ways that
we could approach this.
One way is to realize
that five divided by two,
we could re-express as five divided by two
or as five halves and five
halves is the same thing
as four plus one over two
which is the same thing as
four halves plus one half
which is the same thing
as four halves is two.
Let me do that in a different color.
This part over here is two
and then you have this one half.
So it's the same thing as two and a half
and if we were to
express that as a decimal
that's going to be equal to two
and how many tenths is equal to a half?
Well five tenths is equal to a half.
So five divided by two,
you could say, 2.5.
Now another way that you could
approach this is you say,
five divided by two is the same thing as
50 tenths divided by two.
So let me use a different color here.
So instead of a five, I could say five
is the same thing as 50 tenths,
50 tenths divided by,
divided by two
and so if I have 50 of something
and if I were to divide it by two,
well that's going to result
in 25 of the something.
So this is going to be equal to 25 tenths.
And how would we express
25 tenths as a decimal?
Well, this is going to be equal to,
if I could put some place values here,
so we definitely have five tenths.
I'll put that in the tenths place
and then 20 tenths is the
same thing as two ones.
And that's exactly what we had up here.
Either way, you get 2.5,
two ones and five tenths.